comprendre les réactions à Chud des
ministres et des parlementaires en
direct de la sortie de
l'hémicycle retrouvez-nous tous les
jours en direct pour suivre les temps
fort des textes en séance et des
auditions dans preuve par 3 je mets à
l'épreuve les responsables politiques
sans concession autour de TR temps
forts
le grand rendez-vous politique du soir
qui décrypte l'actualité du
jour le club des municipales c'est le
rendez-vous électoral de l'année sur la
chaîne public sén où j'inviterai autour
de moi l'ensemble de mes confrères pour
débattre etcryter des grands enjeux
locaux de cette
élection déshabillonsles c'est
l'émission où je déshabille les
politique en tout bien tout
honneur en cette année d'élection
municipale itinérar bis reprend la route
à la découverte de ville en pleine
transformation pour une balade dans une
France
inattendue
Europe c'est l'actualité européenne dans
tous ces états dans Génération Europe on
parle des enjeux de l'Europe avec des
étudiants français et
étrangers l'actualité politique vue du
web bibliothèque mic une émission
littéraire reconnue de référence pour
les auteurs leurs livres et pour le
public dans un lieu
exceptionnel culture t c'est l'émission
de tous les arts dans tous les
territoires un lieu une histoire je suis
heureux de vous retrouver pour de
nouvelles conversations sur les haut
lieux de la Grande
Guerre les pieds sur terre c'est le
rendez-vous des
éc enquête d'Europe c'est une manière
singulière de montrer et raconter
l'Europe le docu débat c'est un
documentaire suivi d'un débat pour
prolonger la
discussion
au cumul des indemnités parce que pour
les Français et les sénateurs
proposaient ici au Sénat de ne pas
cumuler ses indemnités absolument donc
et ils ont voté cette disposition ils
ont dit bon quand on est sénateur et
maire par exemple on ne perçoit que
l'indemnité de sénateur et finalement le
mandat de maire il est tellement beau
qu'on peut le faire de manière bénévole
c'est c'est pour montrer aux Français
que l'attachement à ce cumule pour les
sénateurs n'est pas lié à des questions
financières comme bien des gens le
pensent je le regrette et donc j'espère
que ça permettra de rétablir une partie
de la vérité mais le cumule n'est pas
totalement terminé parce qu'on on le
voit au gouvernement il y a 15 ministres
qui vont être candidats aux élections
municipales alors certes pour des postes
de conseillers municipaux qui sont pas
touchés par cette limitation du du cumul
mais il y a donc beaucoup d'hypocrisie
encore dans l'air sur cette question non
mais heureusement il s'agit de ne pas
cumuler un une fonction parlementaire
avec un un mandat un mandat
parlementaire avec un mandat exécutif
local une fonction exécutive locale mais
un mandat local PvE conserver C local
oui mais c'est pas la même chose et ça
sera de moins en moins le cas au fil du
temps puisque là on a cette expérience
pour ceux qui vont arrêter ils ont été
maires ils savent ce que c'est que que
de construire des logements ils savent
ce que c'est que de de faire une crèche
ils savent ce que c'est que de gérer une
école ils savent ce que c'est que de
développer des plans d'urbanisme bref
les maires ils savent tout c'est c'est
eux qui détiennent la la vérité
démocratique en réalité et donc parce
qu'ils connaissent la vie de nos
concitoyens et donc on a à bénéficier
j'allais dire de cette connaissance au
niveau juridique au niveau de de la la
façon de faire les lois d'apporter cette
expérience et donc c'est c'est
regrettable je le crois pour le Sénat
complémentarité avec l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce qu'on contrepartie de
la limitation des des cumules il va
vraiment falloir travailler sur le
statut de l'élu local c'est un vieux
serpent de mer on on sait hier soir il y
a une proposition de loi qui a été votée
en ce sens ici au Sénat qui va revenir
en seconde lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale mais cette proposition elle ne
va peut-être pas assez loin non qu'en
pensez-vous elle elle elle améliore déjà
quand même sensiblement les choses
puisque maintenant tout le monde aura
droit à une couverture sociale c'était
pas le cas encore et puis jusqu'à
jusqu'aux communes de 1000 habitants
cette couverture sociale sera gratuite
pour donc c'est quand même une avancée
mais il faudra aller plus loin pour
permettre est-ce qu'ils fut un salaire
il faut permettre à des à des salariés
la démocratie la démocratie la
démocratie locale excusez-moi de ma
véhémence elle a un coup elle a un coup
parce qu'il faut l'assumer et il faut la
revendiquer même cette démocratie locale
elle a un coup lequel le fonctionnement
et donc il n'est pas anormal qu'il y ait
des indemnités qui permettent à
quelqu'un soit de cumuler son travail
avec une fonction d'exécutif local maire
je dis maire parce que les gens
comprennent maire donc on pourrait être
maire et salarié encore faut-il que ils
a la possibilité d'exercer leur fonction
de maire mais est-ce que vous croyez
qu'en période de crise économique et
morale he de défiance très très forte
vis-à-vis des des politiques on va
pouvoir proposer comme ça un véritable
statut avec un salaire des conditions
matérielles nécessaires pour travailler
au français est-ce que ça va être
accepté par l'opinion publique oui je
pense que les Français sont prêts à
accepter ça pour une une seule catégorie
d'élu les maires parce que c'est les
seuls qui qui sont respectable par les
Français et respectés on va parler la la
décentralisation le ministre chargé des
Relations avec le Parlement l'a annoncé
cette semaine il y aura une loi une
première lecture avant l'été puis je
pense qu'il va le confirmer tout à
l'heure dans l'émicyclle du Sénat
puisqu'il va répondre à une question de
de Jean-Pierre rafarin les régions
tiendront une grande place hein dans ce
dans ce projet de loi sur la
décentralisation euh il y a eu beaucoup
de tâonnement puisque ce projet de loi
va remplacé deux autres qui étaient
prévu hein qui étit préparé par le
cabinet de de marielis Lebranchu
notamment euh les compétences des
régions vont être accrues au détriment
des départements alors non il faut faut
trouver un il faut trouver un moyen
terme mais la vérité c'est que bah c'est
quand même ce qu'a dit le gouvernement
les compétences des régions vont être
accru oui non un pouvoir réglementaire
un pouvoir réglementaire va être délégué
aux régions ça c'est une une une avancée
dans la décentralisation et donc après
il faut trouver un équilibre et cet
équilibre il va il va se faire moi je je
plaide pour la subsidiarité ce qui peut
se faire au plus près doit être fait au
plus près et donc je plaide pour des
couples ça dépend mais je plaide pour
des couples qui soient j'allais dire
commune intercommunalité région mais
pourtant la diversité de notre
territoire est telle que dans certains
départements les conseills généraux sont
indispensables indispensables et donc
Milie rurau en milieu en milieu dans les
milieux rurau que le chef d'État làdus
oui c'est c'est clair vous savez c'est
pas la c'est pas le oui en milieu rural
dans les milieux ruraux dans les milieux
ruraux donc c'est pas la même chose
d'être un département comme le lot la
riège la haute zone et un département
comme le Rône ou un département
intermédiaire comme le en comme la Côte
d'Or où il y a toute à la fois une
grosse agglomération et un gros secteur
rural ou les départements la petite
couronne parisienne qui faudrait
supprimer si vous êtes d'accord avec
Jean-Marc her le terme de
supprimer ah un moment on va bien
falloir rationaliser et faire des coupes
oui non mais moi je suis pour des
transferts de compétences et pas
forcément pour j'allais dire des
décisions qui tombent à la à la hache
comme cela cela dit on est quand on est
dans un un processus tellement urbain ou
tellement urbanisé que celui qu'on
connaît évidemment il faudra simplifier
je dis simplifier plutôt que de
supprimer Marie branju qui était sur le
plateau de public Senat il y a de jours
nous nous l'a confirmé il y aura des
régions qui vont disparaître alors vous
vous êtes pour quelle solution des
fusions
volontaires ou va falloir prendre le
scapel couper découper Marie Lise de
branchu dit des régions vont disparaître
non euh parce que ce qui ce qui fait
l'histoire de la France ne disparaîtra
pas mais le découpage administratif qui
est celui de la France aujourd'hui ne
correspond pas forcément à l'histoire de
notre pays en terme de province et
cetera simplement il faut j'allais dire
des regroupements volontaires et pour
pour que ces regroupements soient
facilités il faut une incitation fiscale
il faut une aide financière donc ça va ê
la méthode de la carotte et du bâton ça
c'est vous qui employez cette expression
mais j'allais dire c'est vrai que c'est
ça marche mieux quand on dit aux élus si
vous vous regroupez si vous avancez
ensemble ben vous serez plus cdé que si
vous ne le faites pas et ça ça marche et
c'est ce qu'il faut faire pour l'instant
on n pas vu beaucoup de volontariat j'ai
pas vu beaucoup de régions qui avaient
envie de fusionner ensemble donc il y a
un moment où il va falloir prendre des
décisions à la place des collectivités
peut-être ou j'ai là j'ai dans mon champ
de de vision le président du conseil
régional de Bourgogne qui je sais a dit
qu'il était prêt à François patria à
envisager un rapprochement alors après
il il y a des phases dans un
rapprochement on décide pas comme ça une
fusion du haut on décide pas de fusion
du haut on décide des rapprochements ça
se fait par étape et c'est mieux et il
sera d'accord avec moi c'est mieux s'il
y a une incitation financière ouais
c'est mieux avec une incitation
financière il va falloir la la
concertation vous y croyez vraiment on a
tellement de mal à bouger quand même les
collectivités territoriales en France on
l'a vu encore ici avec le texte sur les
métropoles à part la métropole de Lyon
tout s'est fait dans la douleur à
Marseille les élus marseillais sont
venus manifester ici dans cette salle
des des conférences le Grand Paris ça
s'est fait aussi dans la douleur c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile ça dépend quel est le
niveau de collectivité qui est concerné
c'est vrai que on peut pas faire les on
peut pas faire des des regroupements du
niveau national imposés au niveau local
sans concertation donc il faut du
dialogue il faut du compromis et c'est
ce que j'appelle le compromis
territorial qu'il faut aujourd'hui acter
pour cela il faut dépasser les limites
partisanes jusqu'à présent il faut un
référendum pour fusionner de
collectivité est-ce qu'il va falloir
revenir sur cette disposition de la
réforme territoriale de 2010 un
référendum préalable à toute fusion
personnellement je ne le pense pas
personnellement je ne le pense pas je
pense que la solution c'est le compromis
territorial la solution c'est le
compromis la solution c'est le dialogue
transpartisan sur ce sujet d'autres
questions François repsamen avant que la
séance ne ne commence manuel Vals le
ministre de l'Intérieur présente
aujourd'hui son bilan de la délinquence
et les chiffres sont mauvais est-ce que
c'est sa méthode qui est à l'épreuve non
non euh tous les chiffres ne sont pas
mauvais ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il y a
une augmentation il l'a constaté
lui-même des vols et cambriolage c'est
vrai que cette augmentation a été
différente suivant les zones parce que
c'est comme ça zone de police plus
importante et zonees de gendarmerie
moins importante mais il y a une
augmentation générale des vols et
cambriolag et manuel Vals a raison de
dire que il faut travailler à
l'international parce qu'il y a eu
multiplication des mafias
étrangères venant de pays de d'Europe je
pense après tout autant dire les choses
clairement je pense à l'Albanie je pense
au Kosovo beaucoup de beaucoup de de
band il y a des pays de des pays aussi
qui sont présents dans l'Union
européenne comme la Roumanie ou la
Bulgarie vous pensez aussi à ces pays-là
en tous les cas il a cité manuel j'ai
manuel Val j'ai écouté sa son
intervention ses remarques il a cité
parce que il y a eu des démantelllements
l'Albanie et le Kosovo donc c'est vrai
qu'il faut amplifier notre coopération
avec ces pays et il faut lutter contre
ces mafias étrangères qui viennent à
grande échelle pratiquer nombre de
cambriolages dans notre pays dernière
question sur Manuel Vals il baisse dans
les sondages alors qu'il caracollé
jusque là en tête est-ce que c'est parce
qu'il donne trop le sentiment de jouer
sa partition en solo non
non mais je pense qu'il était à un tel
niveau un tel niveau de popularité que
je lui aurais souhaité d'y rester mais
c'est pas c'est pas dramatique ce qui
vient de lui arriver je veux dire une
baisse dans les sondage peut-être c'est
un clivage qui s'opère à nouveau droite
gauche voilà mais c'est un bon ministre
d' l'intérieur ouis c'est un bon
ministre de l'Intérieur vous le soutenez
ah oui bien sûr ouais merci beaucoup
François repsamen d'être venu en direct
sur notre plateau je vais vous laisser
rejoindre l'hémicycle du Sénat puisque
la séance des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement va débuter dans quelques
instants je vous rappelle que cette
séance va commencer par une question de
l'ancien Premier ministre Jean-Pierre
rafarin sur la décentralisation et c'est
Alain vidalis le ministre chargé des
Relations avec le Parlement qui va lui
répondre puisque le Premier ministre
Jean-Marc hraud est absent de
l'hémicycle du Sénat cet après-midi
d'autres questions euh cet après-midi
bah sur la politique familiale le
financement des des 30 milliards lacer
l'ancien ministre Jean-Pierre chevedem
au nom du groupe du RDSE des Radicaux de
Gauche ici au Sénat qui va poser cette
question au gouvernement c'est Bernard
casenu le ministre du Budget qui lui
répondra et puis je le disais également
tout à l'heure François Trussy le
sénateur UMP du Var va s'exprimer sur
les inondations dans son département le
weekend dernier et bien sûr là aussi on
attend des réponses concrètes précises
notamment pour les habitants de ce
département sur ces inondations euh
parmi les autres points qui vont être
abordé et bien une question de David
Assouline le porte-parole du Parti
socialiste sur la TVA applicable ou non
à la presse numérique là aussi c'est
Bernard casenuve le ministre chargé du
budget qui va lui répondre et puis
d'autres questions par exemple sur les
OGM ça c'est une question du groupe des
vers du sénateur Joël Labé une question
adressée à Stéphane Lefol des questions
sur les fonds structurels européens donc
vous voyez un panel de thèmes abordés
très très large une dernière question
avec à François repsamen puisque séance
ne démarre pas et que vous êtes resté
avec nous dans une interview au Monde de
ce soir Jean-Pierre inffarin l'ancien
Premier ministre dit qu'il est prêt à
voter la confiance au gouvernement même
si le Sénat ne vote pas la confiance sur
le pacte de responsabilité est-ce qu'il
a finalement il y a une majorité de
centre droite modérée gauche qui
pourrait se dégager autour de ce pacte
de responsabilité non je pense que sa
position elle est elle est tout à fait
respectable elle est c'est une bonne
c'est c'est bien quand il y a un élu
quel que soit son parti euh qui qui dit
parce que je le pense je je le fais j'y
crois je le vote donc moi je dis respect
voilà la séance commence merci François
repsamen on va suivre ces questions
d'actualité au
Gouvernement merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question concerne la
décentralisation la décentralisation
pour notre assemblée ici au Sénat
l'Assemblée des territoires malgré la
contestation malvenue du président de la
commission des lois de la Assemblée
nationale assemblée des territoires pour
nous la décentralisation reste une
grande ambition politique ce n'est pas
un dossier technique et c'est pour ça
que le Sénat n'a pas voulu être dispersé
par une succession de texte mais essayer
de définir une ligne d'horizon de
perspective pour la décentralisation
nous avons ainsi décidé monsieur le
Président sous votre autorité une
mission d'information dont j'étais le
président don monsieur cattinger était
le rapporteur pour essayer de définir un
certain nombre de perspectives nous en
avons trois principal que je veux
rappeler à votre attention la première
c'est la défense de la commune les
maires sont inquiets et au moment où on
va appeler alors renouvellement il faut
les soutenir soutenir la commune premier
espace républicain mais évidemment qui
défend la commune doit défendre
l'intercommunalité parce que la commune
a besoin de solidarité et nous défendons
une intercommunalité d'une manière très
large dans cette assemblée une
intercommunalité collégiale et non pas
hiérarchique deuxième idée très
importante pour défendre la ruralité la
ruralité je sais bien ce n'est que 15
millions de personnes mais c'est 15
millions de personnes qui comptent dans
notre pays et pour défendre ces 15
millions de personnes c'est le
département où se fait l'équilibre entre
le rural et l'urbain je sais qu'on peut
défendre aussi légitimement le
département pour les espaces urbains
mais pour l'équilibre urbain rural le
département est indispensable et qui
défend la ruralité doit défendre le
département en charge de la cohésion
sociale et territoriale 3è idée très
importante puisqu'il nous faut faire des
économies la décentralisation ne peut
pas être exente des économies nationales
à faire il faut faire des économie et
pour ça éviter tous les doublons et
notamment éviter la concurrence entre
les régions et les départements pour
éviter la concurrence entre régions et
département pour éviter la
cantonalisation de la région on fait des
régions plus grandes et des départements
qui restent en charge de la cohésion
mais des régions qui font de la
stratégie qui travaillent sur les
grandes infrastructures sur les grandes
questions universitaires sur la
politique des entreprises des sujets
stratégiques et dans ce contexte là on a
des régions et des départements qui
évitent les doublons et on fait des
économies alors Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est la suivante que quelle
place réser réservez-vous au Sénat dans
les projets du gouvernement en matière
de décentralisation annoncé par le
président de République le Sénat est un
partenaire pour vous fiable quelle place
lui réservez-vous et quelle place
réservez-vous aux idées du Sénat dans
cette
réflexion merci la parole est à Monsieur
Alain vidalis ministre chargé des
Relations avec le Parlement oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre le Premier ministre Jean-Marc
HUD est en déplacement à mess
aujourd'hui avec Madame le branchu et il
m'a chargé comme ministre délégué auprès
de lui de vous répondre puisqu'il aurait
souhaité pouvoir le faire
personnellement votre question rencontre
d'ailleurs très largement les
déclarations du président de la
République qui vient de réaffirmer sa
détermination poursuivre l'effort de
simplification de l'organisation
administrative de no territoire le
gouvernement a été chargé de préparer
donc un second volet de la réforme de la
décentralisation qui permettra de
clarifier les compétences entre les
différents niveaux des collectivités et
ainsi de lutter contre les
enchevêtrements et les trop nombreux
doublons le rôle moteur des régions en
matière de développement économique sera
renforcé par le transfert de nouvelles
compétences de l'État je peux notamment
citer c'est les aides aux entreprises le
soutien à l'innovation concernant les
départements le gouvernement a pris la
pleine mesure de leur action en matière
de cohésion sociale et de solidarité
territoriale pour reprendre votre
expression leurs attributions en ces
domaines seront enrichis et précisés
pour être clair nous sommes nous sommes
opposés à la suppression des département
sur tous le territoirees comme proposé
par exemple par Monsieur Jean-François
Copé ce serait aujourd'hui un non sens
dans les zones rurales notamment il joue
un rôle essentiel pour la cohésion
sociale et territoriale et vous l'avez
dit fort justement pour autant cette
organisation territoriale ne serait
rester figée dans un souci d'efficacité
elle doit aussi permettre aux
collectivités territoriales de s'adapter
aux spécificités de chaque territoire
c'est la raison pour laquelle le projet
de loi de modernisation de l'action
publique territoriale et d'affirmation
des métropoles a créé les conférences
territoriales de l'action publique en
leur sein les représentants des
différentes collectivités de chaque
région auront la possibilité d'affiner
par voies de délégation l'exercice de
leurs compétences face à des régions aux
prérogatives renforcées nous devons
collectivement nous poser la question de
leur nombre de leur taille comme vous
l'avez fait si certaines atteignent déjà
une taille suffisante pour exercer de
nouvelles compétenence d'autres pourrai
être amené à se regrouper ou à
mutualiser leurs services pour les
accompagner nous travaillons à la mise
en œuvre d'incitations financières dans
le calcul des dotations de l'État le
gouvernement souhaite que le débat sur
la carte territoriale ait lieu avec
l'ensemble des forces politiques et à ce
titre vous l'avez rappelé nous le
gouvernement se félicite que le Sénat
d'une certaine façon nous ait devancé à
travers la mission commune d'information
confié à vous-même monsieur le Premier
ministre Jean-Pierre rafarin et à
Monsieur Yve kraattinget et le
gouvernement tient à saluer la qualité
de ce travail et naturellement
poursuivra cette réforme qui a été
engagé avec avec un rôle particulier
pour être à l'écoute non seulement de
vos travaux mais aussi pour poursuivre
le dialogue avec le Sénat merci la
parole à
emmerie de montescu pour le groupe udi
UC monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous avons inlassablement déclaré que
votre augmentation des impôts tuerait
l'impôt que nous assisterions à une
démonstration
InVivo de la courbe de
l'affaire la baisse des recettes
fiscales en est l'illustration les
dernières déclarations du président de
la République sonnent comme un
agjournemento et la prise de conscience
du découragement croissant des
entreprises de depuis 20 mois on peut
chiffrer ces propos une baisse des
charges des entreprises de 50 milliards
et une baisse des impôts sur les ménages
de 6 milliards d'ici
2017 une baisse dès 2015 du déficit
budgétaire de 15 milliards pour parvenir
au 3 %
maestrichichien nous nous y sommes
engagés auprès de la commission c'est la
crédibilité de notre signature sur les
marchés qui est en jeu sans elle le
poids de nos remboursements ne pourra
que
s'alourdir la croissance étant atone les
recettes fiscales se réduisant ou étant
gelé l'équilibre ne pourra se faire
qu'en diminuant les dépenses constitué à
50 % par les salaires il est exclu
d'amputer l'investissement publicque
pour ne pas ajouter la crise à la crise
il faut donc réduire lesp p de
fonctionnement je rappelle que le nombre
des agents publics par habitant est le
plus élevé de l'Union mais je n'imagine
pas que vous envisagiez de diminuer leur
rémunération ou de renoncer au 35 he
hélas unique au monde aussi je
reprendrai les conclusions du
rapport aussi je reprendrai les
conclusions du rapport de la Cour des
comptes de juillet 2012
et paraphraserai Paul kess en affirmant
il ne faut pas seulement dire qu'il faut
diminuer le nombre d'agents publics ou
desmissions mais il faut nous dire
lesquels monsieur le ministre quelle va
être la réduction annuel du nombre
d'agents publics ou des missions que
vous envisagez et dans quel ministère ne
me répondez pas s'il vous plaît que vous
allez créer un nouveau haut comité
consultatif merci la parole est à
Monsieur Bernard casenu ministre chargé
du budget merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur pour cette question qui va
d'abord me donner l'occasion de faire un
point sur les chiffres car je ne sais
pas où vous avez trouvé les vôtres mais
il ne correspondent absolument pas à
ceux qui sont dans les rapports de la
Cour des comptes et du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques d'abord pour ce qui
concerne les déficits je veux bien
admettre qu'ils puissent parfois
diminuer moins vite qu'ils n'ont
augmenté par le passé mais le fait que
les déficit C diminu moins vite qu'ils
nont augmenté par le passé ne signifie
pas qu'ils augmentent alors je voudrais
donner la séquence des la réduction des
déficit public pour que nous disposions
tous des mêmes éléments statistiques et
chiffrés le déficit public lorsque nous
sommes arrivés en 2012 le dernier connu
était de 5,3 %. au terme des efforts que
nous avons pris en loi de finance
rectificative 2012 il était de 4,5 nous
serons autour de 4,1 en 2013 et 3,6 en
2014 nous avons fait un effort for
structurel sans précédent cela a été
reconnu par le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques de 1,3 % en 2012 et de 1,7 %
en 2013 et si je prends pour appuyer le
propos et faire la démonstration jusqu'à
son terme le déficit des comptes sociaux
du régime général et du fond de
solidarité vieillesse il était de plus
de 20 milliards en 2011 il est passé un
peu plus de 17 milliards en 2012 il sera
de
16,2 milliards en 2014 puisque nous
avons sous-exécuté l'ondame à hauteur de
1 milliard et de 12,8 milliards en 2014
c'est-à-dire qu'en l'espace de 20 mois
nous aurons diminué de 8 milliards le
déficit des comptes sociaux là où il
avait spectaculairement augmenté au
cours du dernier quinquena par
conséquent monsieur le sénateur comme
j'ai senti un peu d'angoisse dans votre
question je voulais par la précision de
votre réponse faire en sorte que vous
puissiez partir plus serein de cet
hémicycle après les questions que vous
n'y êtes rentré par ailleurs vous
indiquez les économies mais bien entendu
que nous allons faire des économies nous
allons en faire beaucoup plus et que
vous en avez réalisé là aussi quelques
chiffres qui devrait être de nature à
vous rassurer totalement la dépense
publique a augmenté entre 2007 et 2012
de 170
milliards c'est pas la question mais
c'est ma réponse parce que sur ces
sujetsl il faut être extrêmement précis
10 milliards entre 2007 et 2012 un peu
plus de 2 % d'augmentation de la dépense
publique pendant cette période
on est aujourd'hui à 0,4 % dans le
budget 2014 et nous envisageons de faire
50 milliards entre 2015 2016 2017 alors
vous me direz réussirez-vous à les faire
je veux vous rassurer là aussi monsieur
le sénateur nous les ferons et nous les
ferons avec d'autant plus de crédibilité
que la révision générale des politiques
publiques c'était 10 milliards sur 3 ans
que ce que nous avons fait cette année
c'est 15 milliards sur 1 an par
conséquent nous sommes sur un chemin de
réduction des déficits et de maîtrise de
la dépense qui doit nous conduire à
tenir les engag que nous avons pris
devant l'Union européenne merci la
parole est à David assouine pour le
groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues comme vous le savez la
presse est frappée lourdement par la
crise économique elle subit de plein
fouet aussi la révolution des
technologies de l'information et de la
communication tout est bouleversé
technique de fabrication distribution
métier usage des lecteurs et bien sûr
l'ensemble du modèle économique nous
sommes dans ce moment où l'ancien meurt
et le nouveau peine à accoucher l'enjeu
c'est bien sûr la sauvegarde des titres
et des emplois mais l'enjeu plus global
pour notre société c'est de continuer à
avoir une information de qualité diverse
et pluraliste libre et indépendante
nécessité vital pour notre démocratie
après la disparition des titres
nationaux quelques-uns les menaces sur
de nouveaux titres parmi les plus
prestigieux maintenant c'est la presse
quotidienne régionale qui est aussi en
grand danger pourtant les aides de
l'État sont très importantes mais à
raison elles sont critiquées certains
bénéficiaires sont très loin d'avoir je
cite ce qui est exigé un caractère
général d'intérêt quant à la diffusion
de la pensée pourtant exigé pour
bénéficier de ces aides les répartitions
et priorit aussi sont contestables à la
mesure de cette crise quelle est
l'action du gouvernement pour réformer
ces aides et aider à ce que notre presse
affronte avec succès le défi historique
est devant elle dans ce casre comment et
quand comptez-vous mettre fin à une
injustice fiscale entre la presse papier
et la presse en ligne qui ne bénéficie
pas et de loin du même taux de TVA en
effet le taux de TVA super réduit à 21
sur les ventes n'est pas appliqué à la
presse en ligne pourtant ce n'est pas
l'édition papier qui justifie cette aide
en 2012 1700 entreprises ont bénéficié
de ce dispositif cet avantage fiscal est
la principale aide à la presse au côté
de de l'aide au transport postal au-delà
de l'injustice subie par tel ou tel
titre de presse exclusivement en ligne
ce différentiel de taux de TVA
représente un frein à la nécessaire
modernisation et aux innovation dans
tout le secteur de la presse y compris
traditionnel qui ne se conçoit plus or
le numérique et constitue à la fois un
handicap économique et un frein à la
migration des abonnés papiers vers les
offres
numériques sur ma proposition depuis
plusieurs années le Sénat a voté la fin
de cette injustice je sais que le
gouvernement et la ministre aurélie
philiipetti est sensible et se mobilise
et notamment négocie au niveau européen
pour obtenir cela mais sans attendre
monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement envisage de faire pour
remédier à cette injust
et rendre effective la neutralité
technologique merci la parole à Bernard
casenu merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur David assouine pour cette
question qui me donne l'occasion de Sal
de saluer ce qui a été votre implication
constante sur ce sujet un combat que
vous avez mené avec d'autres sénateurs
pour la neutralité des supports à la
fois pour les objets culturels je pense
notamment à la volonté qui a été la vote
de faire en sorte qu'on aligne la TVA
sur le livre numérique sur celle du
livre taux réduit de TVA à 5,5 vous avez
également mené ce combat pour la presse
en ligne qui est dans une situation un
peu différente du livre puisque pour ce
qui concerne euh la presse en ligne
comme vous le savez le taux de TVA
applicable à la presse en ligne est de à
pardon à la presse papier de 2,1 %. pour
des raisons qui tiennent au fait que au
moment où la directive TVA était
négociée on a appliqué euh le taux euh
qui s'appliquait aux activités lorsqu'il
s'agissait de taux réduit c'est ce qu'on
appelle la clause de gel et à l'époque
où ce taux a été défini la presse
numérique n'existait pas encore et c'est
le résultat du progrès technologique
comme vous l'avez souligné dans votre
question qui a conduit la presse
numérique à se développer en véhiculant
des informations en menant des
investigations qui sont aussi importante
et précieuse pour la démocratie en
France et en Europe que ce que peut
faire la presse pied et par conséquent
pour les mêmes raisons que celles qui
nous ont conduite à nous mobiliser sur
le T 188 de TVA pour le livre numérique
nous avons pris l'engagement et auréli
Philippe ETTI l'a fait au mois de
juillet en conseil des ministres
d'appliquer le taux réduit de TVA à la
presse en ligne il s'avère que ce combat
est un combat qui est partagé par un
très grand nombre de pays de l'Union
européenne faut-il rappeler que dans
laaccord de coalition qui lit les
différents formations politiques
allemandes dans le gouvernement d'Angela
Merkel la mise en place d'un taux réduit
de TVA sur la presse en ligne a été acté
comme un objectif à atteindre et dans le
cadre des consultations en cours
relative à la rédaction de la nouvelle
directive TVA beaucoup de pays de
l'Union européennes nous ont rejoint
dans ce contexte nous pensons que le
moment est venu d'aligner le taux de TVA
applicable à la presse en ligne sur la
presse papier et le gouvernement prendra
une initiative législative dans les
semaines qui viennent pour matérialiser
cette volonté et au moment où cette
initiative législative sera prise de
manière à ne pas perdre de temps nous
prendrons également par instruction des
dispositions qui nous permettront de
faire en sorte que sans tarder sans
délai cet anilement entre dans les faits
nous aurons ainsi répondu à votre
préoccupation et donneré satisfaction au
combat que beaucoup de sénateurs surtout
ces ban mènent depuis de très nombreuses
années merci la parole à Joë Labé pour
le groupe écologiste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers
collègues ma question concernera les OGM
mais au
préalable je souhaiterais puisque c'est
arrivé aujourd'hui permettez-moi de vous
dire avec mes camarades écologistes
notre grande satisfaction d'avoir vu ce
matin l'assemblée nationale adopter
conforme notre proposition de loi visant
à mieux encadrer l'usage des
pesticides ma question s'adresse à à
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt et
concerne la procédure d'autorisation par
l'Union européenne de l'OGM TC 15507 et
le maintien d'un moratoire sur le maïs
OGM MON
810 les États-membres de l'Union
européenne doivent se prononcer avant le
12 février sur une demande
d'autorisation de l'OGM
tc1507 proposée par la Commission
européenne en l'absence de majorité
qualifiée lors de ce vote la Commission
pourrait valider cette proposition alors
même que le Parlement européen a adopté
une résolution contre cette autorisation
aussi nous demandons et nous comptons
sur le poids du gouvernement français
pour refuser cette autorisation et
défendre la sécurisation des procédures
d'autorisation des OGM nous tenons à
pointer une seconde urgence nationale
cette fois il s'agit du maïs mont810
l'arrêté d'interdiction de ce maïs OGM
pris par le gouvernement français en
mars 2012 avait été annulé par une
décision du Conseil d'État par un
communiqué du 1er août de l'année
dernière vous avez confirmé monsieur le
ministre l'engagement du gouvernement à
la conférence environnementale de
septembre 2012 de maintenir le moratoire
sur la culture des semences EGM afin de
prévenir les risques environnementaux et
économiques pour les autres cultures et
pour
l'apiculture cela en recherchant un
cadre réglementaire adapté durablement
au respect de ces objectifs vous avez
aussi affirmé par ce commun qu que
qu'une décision serait prise avant le
prochain semi qui aura lieu entre avril
et juin 2014 on y arrive et c'est donc
très prochainement alors en cette
période importante où nous étudions la
loi d'avenir agricole que vous nous
proposez monsieur le ministre dont le
socle et l'agroécologie pratique au
carrefour de l'agronomie de l'écologie
et des sciences sociales pratique qui ne
porte pas dans ces gênes du tout les OGM
ma question est de savoir quelle
décision vous vous préparez à prendre
afin d'en préserver durablement et nous
le souhaitons définitivement notre
territoire je vous remercie
merci la parole à Monsieur Stéphane
Lefol ministre de l'Agriculture monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Député monsieur
le sénateur jeallis faire
un les couleurs sont à peu près les
mêmes mais nous ne sommes pas dans la
même
assemblée je voulais répondre à votre
question il y a d'abord deux éléments
dans votre question il y a des questions
posées sur
une dimension d'urgence liée à une
autorisation d'un OGM en l'occurrence un
OGM qui a un numéro assez particulier le
507 et puis a la question plus vaste
posée sur la question des règles qui
s'appliqueraient dans le cadre européen
rediscuté et renouvelés des
autorisations ou des possibilités qui
serait donné aux état d'accepter ou de
refuser le recours aux OGM donc il y a
deux questions sur la première qui
concerne l'immédiia et l'actualité celle
du fameux maïs 507 la position de la
France est très claire elle a été
exprimé à chaque rencontre que nous
avons pu avoir c'est que nous ne sommes
pas d'accord pour que cette autorisation
soit donnée pour des raisons d'ailleurs
à la fois de fond et aussi sur une
raison simple c'est que la l'fsa a
demandé à cette entreprise de préciser
un certain nombre de règles en
particulier sur les impacts
environnementaux de ce maïs qui n'ont
toujours toujours pas été rendu par
l'entreprise et qu'en conséquence de
quoi même en terme juridique par rapport
au positions de l'fsa il y a pas de
raison de l'autoriser c'est le premier
point le deuxième c'est d'avoir un lieu
de débat au niveau européen au niveau du
Conseil des ministres ça ne peut pas
être celui du Conseil des ministres de
l'Agriculture ça sera à la demande de la
France et nous avons travaillé avec
Thierry Repentin le ministre le Conseil
des ministres sur les affaires générales
le 11 février qui aura à a traité de
cette question dans le cadre d'un débat
puisque c'est un point à l'ordre du jour
au point B donc il y aura bien un débat
sur ce sujet c'est ce que souhaiter la
France chacun doit exprimer sa position
sur ce sujet et la position de la France
je le rappelle ici c'est de ne pas
accepter cette autorisation premier
point deuxième point plus vaste et plus
global sur cette question globale qui
est posée depuis longtemps sur les
organismees génétiquement modifiés c'est
les règles qui régissent à l'échelle
européenne les choix Cho que peuvent
faire les états vous avez un maïs qui
est autorisé aujourd'hui qui s'appelle
le maïs Monsanto
810 et c'est sur la base de clauses de
sauvegarde que la France aujourd'hui par
exemple n'autorise pas le fait de
d'avoir recours au Semens de ce maïs
clauses de sauvegarde qui sont
contestées et juridiquement contestables
il faut qu'à l'échelle de l'Europe on
soit capable de définir une
réglementation et un cadre juridique qui
permette d'avoir pour les états des
choix objectifs sur le fait qu'on
autorise ou qu'on n'autorise pas le
recours à un OGM qui aura été autorisé à
l'échelle de l'Europe c'est ça l'enjeu
mais ça c'est un enjeu de deuxème temps
c'est un enjeu de discussion et de
négociation sur le cadre juridique donc
pour répondre à votre question
premièrement la France est contre
l'autorisation de ce maïs deuxièmement
elle minite pour un changement du cadre
juridique actuel merci la parole à
Monsieur é be pour le groupe CC bien
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
au lendemain du 2 anniversaire d'un
grand discours prononcé par un candidat
à l'élection présidentielle de 2012 au
Bourget j'en citerai une phrase sous nos
yeux en 20 ans la finance a pris le
contrôle de l'économie de la société et
même de nos vies fin de citation le 24
décembre dernier nous apprenions par la
presse que l'Autorité des marchés
financiers avait procédé au
renouvellement de 6 membres de la
commission des sanctions qui existent en
son sain rappelons si nécessaire le rôle
de l'Autorité des marchés financiers tel
qu'il est défini sur son site internet
je cite elle est une autorité publique
indépendante qui régule les acteurs de
la place financière française et lorsque
c'est nécessaire c'est elle qui contrôle
enquête et sanctionne fin de
citation nous avons avons pu noter la
nomination au sein de cette instance
d'une représentante de la banque suisse
UBS une personne jusque-là en charge de
la conformité au sein de la banque vous
le savez monsieur le ministre la banque
UBS fait l'objet d'une enquête depuis
février 2012 sanctionné en juin 2012
d'une amende de 10 millions d'euros par
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel pour
je cite l'accisme dans le contrôle des
pratiques
commerciales l'information judiciaire
ouverte à Paris Porte sur le motif
suivant démarchage bancaire ou financier
par personnes non habilité et
blanchiment de fraudes fiscal et de
fonds obtenus à l'aide d'un démarchage
illicite commis en bande
organisée vous conviendrez monsieur le
ministre chers collègues que le
télescopage entre les term de la
doctrine de l'Autorité des marchés
financiers et ceux décrivant les fait
reprochés à la banque est assez
saisissant ma question sera double
monsieur le ministre la première quels
sont les critères qui ont présidé à la
désignation de la représent de la banque
UBS au sein de la commission des
sanctions de l'Autorité des marchés
financiers la deuxième diriez-vous que
cette décision est de nature à nous
préserver du contrôle par la finance de
l'économie de la société et même de nos
vies je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Bernard
casenev monsieur le sénateur Éric Boquet
j'ai c'est l'intensité du combat que
vous menez pour lutter contre la finance
devenue dément vous le faites en animant
une commission sur les paradis fiscaux
et sur la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
qui fait un travail remarquable et tout
au long des débats que nous avons eu à
l'occasion de l'examen des lois
financières vous avez témoigné de votre
détermination et je veux la saluer ici
mais je veux aussi vous indiquer que
votre détermination n'a d'égale que la
nôtre en ces matières c'est la raison
pour laquelle depuis que nous sommes en
situation de
responsabilité nous avons pris un
ensemble de dispositions qui devrai
totalement vous satisfaire puisque elles
vont dans le sens des préoccupations que
vous avez exprimé à travers votre
question faut-il rappeler les 60 mesures
qui ont été prises depuis le début du
quinquena pour lutter contre la fraude
fiscal qu'il s'agisse des dispositions
relatives à l'inversion de la charge de
la preuve pour ce qui concerne le
transfert des bénéfices qu'il s'agisse
des conditions beaucoup plus restreintes
de déduction des intérêts d'emprunt des
bénéfices pour éviter l'optimisation
fiscale qu'il s'agisse à travers la loi
que nous avons présenté avec Christian
tobira devant votre assemblée et qui
durcisse considérablement les peines qui
s'appliquent à ceux qui se livre à de la
fraude fiscale en utilisant notamment le
recours à des sociétés écran qu'il
s'agisse également du combat que nous
menons au plan européen avec Pierre
Moscovici pour faire en sorte que il y
ait des des échanges automatiques
d'information au sein de l'Union
européenne qui permettent de faire en
sorte que l'Europe soit elle-même
mandaté pour que ces conventions soient
signées au plan international et que
nous puissions avoir une véritable liste
européenn d'états et territoires non
coopératifs toutes ces actions là nous
ont conduit à obtenir des résultat en
matière de lutte contre la fraude et
maîtrise de la finance que aucun
gouvernement avant nous n'aveit obtenu
je veux notamment évoquer l'objectif que
nous sommes assignés pour 2014 de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale qui nous
conduit à escompter de la lutte contre
la fraude fiscale près de 2 milliards de
recettes et par ailleurs je veux vous
indiquer que au terme de la circulaire
que j'ai prise au mois de juin dernier
c'est d'ors et déjà 11000 dossiers qui
ont été déposés devant l'administration
fiscale qui nous permettent d'avoir plus
d'un milliards de recettes pour l'année
prochaine pour ce qui concerne la
question que vous m'avez
posée mais qui n'est pas sans relation
collatérale avec ce que je viens
d'évoquer avec beaucoup de précision
pour ce qui concerne cette question qui
pour qui concerne cette mais je reviens
quand vous voulez le plaisir d'être avec
vous est sans limite sil vous plaît
monsieur le ministre si vous vouz bien
pour ce qui concerne la question
monsieur le sénateur que vous avez posé
comme vous l'avez soulignez vous-même
elle fait l'objet de procédure à
caractère judiciaire concernant cette
banque et les obligations qui sont les
miennes m'interdit sachant les choses
que tout le monde ne peut pas savoir de
faire des commentaires de manière à ne
pas obérer l'efficacité des procédures
en question merci la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Pierre chevvenem pour le
groupe
RDSE oui ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l' des finances
monsieur le ministre dans sa dernière
conférence de presse qui allant pas
douter marquera son quinquena le
président de la République a décidé pour
renforcer la compétitivité des
entreprises françaises de supprimer
d'ici 2017 les cotisations familial qui
pèse sur les salaires à hauteur de 30
milliards d'euros cette mesure est
conforme aux préconisations du rapport
galoi faute qu'il soit possible dans le
système de la monnaie unique d'effectuer
la dévaluation qui permettrait de rendre
compétitive notre économie le rapport
Galoa prévoyait cependant de compenser
par un relèvement de la 16g la perte des
recettes des caisses d'allocation
familial c'est une toute autre voix qu'a
dessiné le président de la République en
proposant un effort d'économie
équivalent et même supérieur sur les
dépenses publiques à hauteur d'au moins
50 milliards d'euros d'ici
2007 un conseil stratégique de la
dépense publique s tenu ce matin sous la
présidence du Président de la République
auquel vous avez assisté en tant que
ministre compétent à tous les égards de
ce terme monsieur le ministre par quel
canal le Gouvernement entend-il
maintenir les ressources des caisses
d'allocation familiale celles-ci
bénéficieront-elles d'une garantie de
ressources équivalente indexée sur la
progression de la masse salariale à
défaut vous le savez bien c'est toute
notre politique familiale qui risquerait
d'être remise en cause alors que les
effets de la crise se font sentir pour
la première fois sur l'indice de
fécondité qui vient de passer en dessous
de
de pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus
que le rappel des progrès déjà faits sur
l'égissement d'économie que vous
envisagez plus vous avancerez sur la
voie des économies et plus celle-ci vous
le savez bien seront difficiles les
fusions de régions ne peuvent dégager
que des écon omie marginale une idée que
nous avons combattu enfin que moi j'ai
combattu en 2010 sous la présidence de
Monsieur Sarkozy peut-elle devenir bonne
par le seul effet d'un changement de
quinquena les pistes envisagées jusqu'à
présent nécessite toute monsieur le
ministre de donner du temps au temps
pour reprendre la formule de François
miteron c'est pourquoi je souhaiterais
monsieur le ministre que vous nous
éclairiez sur les principaux gisements
d'économie je ne vous en demande pas
plus je vous demande pas nous indiquer
dès maintenant lesquels mais que vous
ayez la gentillesse de nous faire une
revue même très
général économie que vous considérerez
comme exploitable à court terme
j'aimerais aussi être rassuré comme
beaucoup sur l'avenir des allocations
familiales et du pouvoir d'achat des
familles je vous en remercie par avance
merci la parole à Monsieur Bernard
casenu bien monsieur le sénateur jeanpre
merci beaucoup pour votre question qui
repose sur deux points d'abord vous
m'interrogez sur le fait de savoir
comment la réforme du financement de la
branche famille va impacter les
prestations et quelle est la stratégie
qui est la nôtre de redressement aussi
et des finances de cette branche et puis
la deuxième question que vous me posez
c'est de savoir dès lors qu'il faut
faire 50 milliards d'économie en 2015
2016- 2017 quels sont les voix quels
sont les sujets quels sont les moyens
que nous allons mobiliser pour atteindre
l'objectif et je veux donc répondre à
ces deux questions pour ce qui concerne
la première question comme vous le savez
lorsque nous sommes arrivés en situation
de responsabilité le déficit de la
branche famille était de 2,5 milliards
ce déficit était le principal obstacle
au maintien des prestations familiales
et à poursuite de la politique familiale
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès l'an
dernier sans attendre le gouvernement a
pris des dispositions de redressement de
la branche famille ces dispositions nous
conduisent à faire 800 millions
d'économies en 2014 et 2015 sur cette
branche 400 millions en 2014 le solde en
2015 par notamment un effort de gestion
des caisses résultants de la mise en
œuvre des contrats d'objectif et de
gestion à hauteur de 500 millions et et
également ce que nous avons fait pour
établir les comptes de la branche
famille s'est traduit par une mesure de
cootient familial qui a été discuté ici
qui a parfois été stigmatisé comme une
mesure à but exclusivement fiscal alors
qu'il s'agissait de rétablir des comptes
qui nous avaient été laissés dégradés je
veux ajouter pour vous vous rassurer
monsieur le sénateur que ce que nous
faisons sur la branche famille ne remet
pas en cause les prestations puisque
nous allons ouvrir 275000 places de
crches supplémentaires que nous
augmentons de 25 et 50 % la loocation
de la loocation familiale et le
complément familial donc nous sommes
vraiment dans une stratégie qui est une
stratégie qui consiste à faire en sorte
que dans le cadre du plan en pauvreté
grande pauvreté les prestations
familiales aillent vers ceux qui ont le
plus besoin nous faisons un effort de
gestion pour cela quelles sont les
pistes d'économie pour demain d'abord
les économies faites sur la branche
retraite et sur la branche famille vont
monter en puissance à hauteur de 4
milliards d'euros sur la période qui
s'ouvre devant nous deuxièmement
l'effort que nous faisons de maîtrise
des dépenses de l'État et de l'assurance
maladie par les normes et notamment la
norme zéro valeur devrait permettre de
dégager 20 milliards nous allons faire
le sol par des réformes structurelles
qui sont destinées par un travail sur
les organisations par des véritables
réformes de structure à faire en sorte
que nos services publics dégagent des
économies montent en gamme sans que ni
les services publics ni notre système de
protection sociale ne soit remise ente
merci la parole est à Jean biset pour le
groupe
UMP monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues avant de de me retourner vers
le ministre en charge des affaires
européennes je voudrais monsieur le
Président me réjouir de pouvoir
m'exprimer cet après-midi n'ayant pas pu
le faire ce matin dans un débat qui n'en
était pas un et pourtant qui était
fondamental puisqu'il s'adressait si
vous voulez à une question à savoir
l'avenir de la filière nucléaire
française où le ministre en charge des
relations avec le Parlement n'a pas pu
lui-même s'exprimer et je déplore cela
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
à moins que à moins que je ne voudrais
pas l'imaginer le gouvernement n' pas
été mécontent de ne pas avoir eu à
clarifier sa position sur le sujet au
moment où au moment où la Commission
européenne invite les différents
États-membres précisément à
réindustrialiser l'Europe et je le
diraiis en boutade et je pense pas que
monsieur le ministre du Budget Bernard
cas ne me démentira ce n'est pas avec
des moulins avant qu'on
réindustrialisera notre pays maintenant
je me retourne vers le ministre chargé
des Relations chargé des affaires
européennes fin décembre la France a
communiqué aux autorités européennes
l'accord de partenariat qui contient la
stratégie d'investissement de notre pays
déclinant la politique européenne de de
cohésion pour la période
2014-2020 c'est une question à 24,3
milliards d'euros cet accord de
partenariat doit maintenant être validé
afin que soi lancé les programmes
opérationnels qui bénéficieront des
fonds structurels européens dans cette
perspective plusieurs sujets nous
inquiètent monsieur le ministre tout
d'abord la finalisation des programmes
opérationnels semble devoir prendre plus
d'un an ce retard ne risque-t-il pas de
devenir un handicap pour bénéficier des
financements surtout qu'il y a désormais
un bonus entre parenthèses de 7 % sur
l'ensemble des crédits pour les régions
qui auront le mieux consommé les crédits
disponibles c'est-à-dire qui les auront
consommé le plus rapidement possible
2èmement l'accord de partenariat que
vous proposez est plutôt un catalogue
d'investissement possible comment
allez-vous assurer une politique lisible
et cohérente sur l'ensemble du
territoire national enfin désormais ce
sont les régions qui onuront la
responsabilité de la gestion des projets
auront-elles rapidement les compétences
correspondantes va-t-il avoir des des
transferts de personnel d'esgar est-ce
compatible avec vos objectifs de
réduction des dépenses publiques enfin
quel garantie avons-nous que ces fonds
soient utilisés en toute transparence et
que les élus régionaux d'opposition ne
soient pas discriminés dans les projet
qu'il soutiennent je vous remercie merci
la parole à Thierry Repentin ministre
des affaires européennes oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur c'est une
excellente nouvelle dont vous me
permettez de parler puisqueeffectivement
malgré des des contraintes budgétaires
existantes à au niveau de l'Union
européenne je peux annoncer que la
France ne souffrira d'aucune restriction
sur la période 2014-2020 dans l'emploi
des fonds structurels près de 16
milliards d'euros Fed FSE mais également
d'une enveloppe de 12 près de 12
milliards d'euros au titre du 2ème
pilier de la politique agricole commune
désormais plus proche plus verte et plus
juste grâce à Stéphane Lefol c'est un
vrai succès de la diplomatie frç sur la
scène européenne et nous devons tous
nous en réjouir car c'est de l'argent
qui va irriguer nos territoire et la
décentralisation de ces crédits voulu
par le Président de la République c'est
une pratique qui nous rapproche de ce
qui se fait dans d'autres pays de
l'Union européenne mais c'est aussi il
faut le voir comme ça un acte de
confiance à l'égard des élus dans
l'ensemble des territoires régionaux
c'est un acte de confiance dans la
capacité à porter des projets de de
développement de vraie stratégie et il
ne faut pas craindre finalement ce qui a
été fait à titre expérimental des
services de l'État qui sont nécessaires
à l'exercice de ces compétences
décentralisées c'est vous qui les avez
voté à travers la loi de modernisation
de l'action publique territoriale et
d'affirmation des métropoles c'est à
l'intérieur quant à la question des
transferts de personnel elle a fait
l'objet d'une circulaire envoyé au
préfet de région le 16 décembre dernier
il reste aujourd'hui un décret en
Conseil d'État et un décret simple
s'agissant de la convention type qui
sera publiée dans quelques jours quant à
la réserve de performance de 7 % elle
n'interviendra qu'en 2019 donc aucun
mois ne sera perdu et je pense que nous
devons passer les uns les autres toutes
nos énergies là où nous sommes en
responsabilité pour la consommation de
ces 27 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui
disponibles pour les territoires merci
la parole à Françoise cartran pour le
groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
déléguée à la réussite éducative c'est
l'un des chantiers de la refondation de
l'école et l'un des plus importants qui
a été lancé par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et le ministre en
charge de la ville la réforme de
l'éducation prioritaire un plan
ambitieux avec des mesures concrètes
forte centré sur la pédagogie et soutenu
par des moyens importants un plan
nécessaire de justice sociale en effet
initié au début des années 80 la
politique d'éducation prioritaire
défendit un objectif donner plus à ceux
qui ont moins donner plus aux
territoires et aux établissements qui
concentrre le plus de difficultés 30 ans
après force pour nous est de constater
les résultats ne sont pas à la hauteur
de nos espérances la France reste le
pays développé où le poids des origines
sociales de même ces équipes doivent
pouvoir bénéficier d'une formation
adaptée et de perspective de carrière
amélioré oui refonder l'école c'est
refonder l'éducation prioritaire aussi
madame la ministre ma question est la
suivante quels sont les moyens que vous
entendez donner et selon quel calendrier
pour soutenir cette nécessaire
continuité dans l'accompagnement
pédagogique des 20 % des élèves inscrits
aujourd'hui dans une zone d'éducation
priorit
qu'elle soit urbaine ou rurale merci la
parole est à Madame George Paul enjevin
ministre chargée de la réussite
éducative merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Françoise Cartron je
crois que effectivement en abordant
cette question de l'éducation
prioritaire nous arrivons à un moment
central de la loi refondation que nous
sommes en train d'opérer comme vous
l'avez dit les résultats dans notre pays
et ça a été encore confirmé par le
rapport PISA ne sont pas quelque chose
que nous pouvons accepter puisque
effectivement dans les quartiers
prioritaires dans les quartiers de la
politique de la ville et bien les
enfants modestes ne sont pas du tout à
la hauteur des apprentissages qu'il
devrai avoir et ceci effectivement il y
a des équipes enseignantes qui sont
remarquables je suis allé ce matin
encore à Marseille et je considère que
certains oui absolument et j'ai vu deux
collègues où il se fait des choses il se
fait des choses magnifiques et je
considère que véritablement les
enseignants qui sont dans ces quartiers
véritablement font honneur à notre pays
et ils ont une tâche qui n'est pas
facile mais justement il faut que N
absolument ce sont des gens remarquables
et on ne le dit pas suffisamment et bien
cette refondation de l'éducation
prioritaire et bien ellea d'abord à
concentrer les moyens que nous accordons
aux équipes à l'éducation nationale dans
les quartiers ils sont nécessaires
c'est-à-dire que les postes débloqués
pour plus de maîtres que de classe pour
la scolarisation des moins de 3 ans
seront implantés d'abord dans ces
quartiers où on en a le plus besoin les
personnels non enseignants c'est-à-dire
les infirmières les assistantes sociales
ont aussi un rôle important à jouer dans
ces quartiers où justement les enfants
ont des problèmes de santé les enfants
ont besoin de parler et par conséquent
ils sont tout à fait précieux il s'agit
aussi
de d'améliorer le climat scolaire et les
assistants d'éducation les assistants de
prévention seront eux aussi présents
davantage encore dans ces établissements
il s'agit d'améliorer les relations
partenariales de l'école et surtout dans
des quartier où parfois les parents sont
éloignés des codes de l'institution
scolaire il faut améliorer la relation
avec les parents car il faut qu'il y ait
une convergence des efforts pour que
l'enfant soit élevé dans une
conditionition suffisante je voudrais
dire aussi qu'une réforme qui me semble
importante c'est que les enfants de 6e
seront pris en charge d'une manière
continue c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'auront
plus l'occasion de sortir à l'extérieur
entre deux cours entre deux cours et
bien on s fera en sorte qu'ils aient des
cours de soutien de l'accompagnement
pédagogique du tutorat des moyens
numériques nouveaux et enfin pour les
enseignants il y a bien entendu un une
amélioration matérielle pour tenir
compte de leur investissement mais il y
aura surtout du temps pour qu'ils
puissent travailler en
pour qu'il puisse effectivement se
concerter monter des projets c'est une
belle réforme elle sera de longue mais
je crois qu'elle est indispensable pour
que aucun jeune de France n'it le
sentiment qu'il est resté sur le bord du
chemin très bien merci la parole la
parole est à lucvounas pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à Madame sylvia
Pinel ministre de l'Artisanat du
Commerce et du Tourisme madame la
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
l'emploi reste la priorité du président
de la République du gouvernement ainsi
que de notre majorité il est un secteur
de notre économie formidable atout
stratégique pour la France qui a été
trop longtemps délaissé voire parfois
méprisé par les décideurs publics
représentant pourtant 7 % de notre PIB
employant 2 millions de personnes de
manière directe et indirecte mais aussi
offrant à notre pays une balance
commerciale excédentaire de 12 milliards
d'euros l'industrie du tourisme de
aujourd'hu d connaître une véritable
révolution industrielle et culturelle
c'est donc à juste titre que le
Président de la République a rappelé à
la fin du mois d'août dernier lors de la
conférence des ambassadeurs que
l'industrie du tourisme méritait d'être
une grande cause nationale il a fixé
deux objectifs le premier consiste à
maintenir la France à son premier rang
mondial en terme de visiteur dans notre
pays dans un deuxième temps notre
industrie du tourisme devra dégager le
premier solde européen en terme de
recette pour y parvenir madame la
ministre vous avez initié les Assises
Nationales du tourisme et je ne peux que
vous soutenir dans votre démarche arme
anti-chômage vitrine du made in France
révolution industrielle et technologique
l'industrie du tourisme doit être
considérée à sa juste valeur madame la
ministre pouvez-vous dans cette optique
présenter à notre Haute Assemblée les
objectifs de ces Assises Nationales du
tourises que vous pilotez en rappelant
aussi l'importance de ce secteur dans la
bataille que nous menons pour l'emploi
je vous remercie merci la parole à
Sylvia Pinel ministre de l'Artisanat
Commerce et du Tourisme merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Luc
carbounas vous avez raison de rappeler
l'importance économique du tourisme dans
notre pays vous avez rappelé les
chiffres plus de 83 millions de
visiteurs 7 % du PIB 12 milliards
d'euros de recettees c'est un secteur
important qui contribue à la croissance
à la création d'emploi mais ce secteur
qui a longtemps été délaissé depuis fort
longtemps des réunions
interministérielles n'avait pas été
organisé pour donner un nouveau souffle
une nouvelle impulsion à notre politique
touristique afin effectivement de créer
de la croissance de créer des emplois et
de diversifier nos destinations puisque
notre pays représente à compte beaucoup
d'atout c'est la raison pour laquelle le
Premier ministre a installé les Assises
du tourisme tour de neuf priorités de
neuf thématiques essentielles et je
tiens à saluer votre participation et
votre implication puisque vous copilotez
un groupe particulièrement important sur
l'adaptation de la filière aux mutations
du secteur et je veux aussi saluer
l'implication des autres pilotes et des
autres personnes qui s'impliquent
puisque plus de 400 personnalités
qualifiées sont associées à ce grand
débat national 19 s'agit pas uniquement
des thématiques que qui nous réunissent
régulièrement à Paris nous avons voulu
impliquer impliquer les Français autour
du d'un site internet pour que nous
puissions recueillir leurs propositions
leurs contributions également des assise
territoriales en région et dans les
outres-merses se dérouleront et vont
prochainement être organisé dans le
territoire dont vous êtes l'élu pour
justement prendre en compte les
spécificités territoriales l'enjeu est
bien de de remplir les objectifs fixés
par le Président de la République et de
moderniser notre offre d'être innovant
d'être dynamique sur ce secteur qui est
de plus en plus concurrentiel de créer
des emplois et de créer dans cette
filière des métiers des métiers d'avenir
des métiers d'excellence puisque vous le
savez 50000 postes chaque année trouvent
du ont du mal à être pourvu ou ne sont
pas pourvus c'est la raison pour
laquelle cela demande une implication
majeure de l'ensemble des acteurs des
collectivités territoriales mais
également des professionnels au sens
large parce que c'est une politique
transversale et j'invite l'ensemble des
parlementaires et des élus locaux des
professionnels à se rassembler sur cette
thématique qui est un beau projet un
beau projet pour la France un beau
projet pour notre image à
l'international et qui mériterait
beaucoup plus du rassemblement de
fédérer les énergies et de contribuer
positivement à la croissance à la
création d'emploi et au redressement de
notre pays très bien merci la parole à
présent notre collègue François Trussy
pour le groupe UMP oui ou ça va ça va ça
va monsieur le Président merci mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes très
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
j'y associe si vous le permettez mes
collègues Falco et Colomba sénateur du
Var monsieur le ministre avec le Premier
ministre vous vous êtes rendu en urgence
dans leev et nous vous en remercions
vous avez compté comme nous les morts
qui s'ajoutent aux 23 morts de
Draguignan en 2010 plus le suicide d'un
agriculteur hier matin vous avez des
visisus constater l'énormité et la
gravité des dégâts dont souffre la
population varoise famille cultivateurs
éleveurs artisans commerçant les
entreprises du Var 1900 habitations
dévastées 600 véhicules et 100 bateaux
détruits la reproduction spectaculaire
de ces catastrophes dites naturelles
nous pose un grave problème les
départements du Sud au cours de ces
dernières années ont produit beaucoup
d'effort d'énormes efforts coûteux mais
indispensables pour prévenir leurs
incendies de forêt et lutter contre eux
nous avons toujours pu compter sur la
solidarité des départements voisins et
de l'État mais monsieur le ministre il n
est pas de même pour les inondations là
tout reste ou presque tout reste à faire
or le Sénat a travaillé sur cette
question la mission commune
d'information présidé par le sénateur
Louis neg des Alpes Maritimes et dont le
rapporteur est Pierre Colomba du Var a
réalisé l'an dernier un remarquable
travail précis réaliste sans concession
y compris à l'égard de certains services
de l'État dont l'action sans
discernement sur le terrain est
spécialement néfaste une proposition de
loi sur la prévention des inondations a
été adoptée ici dans un temps record à
l'unanimité et elle a déjà formulé
nombre de propositions une partie
d'entre elles n'ont-elles pas été
reprises par Madame le Ministre
Lebranchu dans la loi sur les
territoires et les métropoles mais
beaucoup reste à faire énormément reste
à faire monsieur le ministre l'intérieur
mais si vous me permettez mesdames et
messieurs tous les ministres faites tous
ce que ce pour que ce me de sécurité
majeur des inondations dans le sud ou
ailleurs soit pris en compte par le
gouvernement et tout le gouvernement
pour ce qu'il concerne faute de quoi le
rapport du Sénat ira rejoindre dans les
oubliettes du Parlement la multitude des
rapports inutilisés qui
croupiss merci merci pour vous répondre
la parole à Alain vidalis ministre
chargé des Relations avec le Parlement
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Sénateur manuel Vals regrette de ne
pouvoir vous répondre personnellement
comme vous l'avez rappelé il s'est rendu
lundi dans le Var avec le Premier
ministre et le ministre de l'écologie
c'est le devoir de l'État d'être au côté
des habitants des sinistrés qui vivent
une situation difficile j'ai bien sûr
comme vous une pensée pour les familles
des victimes c'est une opération de
secours de grande ampleur et périlleuse
qu'il a fallu organiser dimanche
notamment à La Londe des mort une
opération comme on en voit rarement avec
plus de 200 élitreyage l'engagement des
acteurs du secours doit être salué face
au drame la mobilisation a été totale et
la solidarité nationale s'est pleinement
exprimé la catastrophe passée l'état
n'abandonnera pas les territoires
sinistrés il sera présent pour
accompagner le retour à la vie normale
les arrêtés de classement en catastrophe
naturelle seront pris dans les prochains
jours manuel Vals a également décidé de
laisser sur place les moyens militaires
de la sécurité civile il y a un chantier
immense de nettoyage de mise en sécurité
des cours d'eau des routes qui doivent
être mené à bien c'est la priorité des
priorités mais vous l'avez dit répondre
à ces drames c'est aussi les prévenir au
mieux aujourd'hui 17 millions de
Français vivent en zone inondable en
matière de prévention l'action et la
détermination de ce gouvernement ont
également permis des avancées sous
l'impulsion de Philippe Martin dans le
Var le le préfet a ainsi entamé avec les
collectivités locales une série de
réunions pour la mise en place rapide de
projets de prévention des risques
d'inondation qui sont l'outil essentiel
de la prévention les collectivités
doivent en effet être pleinement
impliqué dans la prévention à
l'initiative de votre collègue Colomba
une nouvelle compétence en matière de
prévention des inondations a été
introduite dans la loi sur les
métropoles il faudra bien sûr faire
vivre cette compétence et cela est rendu
possible par la création d'un mode de
financement adapté face aux répétitions
des catastrophes naturelles notre pays
doit également développer une vraie
culture du risque c'était l'objet des
excellents rapports produits par votre
assemblée je pense comme vous l'avez
fait au rapport de Louis Nère et de
Pierre Yve Colomba mais aussi à
l'important travail d'Alain Anziani et
Bruno retaillot sur les submersions
marines je viens je tiens à vous
rassurer
ce travail n'est pas resté et ne restera
pas lettre MTE des progrès ont déjà été
accomplis d'autres c'est certains reste
à faire mais toujours que ce soit en
Bretagne à la Réunion dans la Drome ou
aujourd'hui dans le Var l'État sera
présent au côté des population
sinistrée merci mes chers collègues nous
en avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement je vais
suspendre la séance voilà pour cette
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct du Sénat on se retrouve tout de
suite avec nos invités pour refaire
ensemble la
séance bonjour à tous merci d'être avec
nous en direct du Sénat après la séance
des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement en direct sur notre antenne
aujourd'hui et bien on refait cette
séance avec nos invités sur le plateau
et on commence tout de suite avec la
porte-parole du gouvernement nadjad Valo
balkassam bonjour
merci d'être sur notre plateau puisque
nous